so uh the other thing is uh I got a uh I
spoke to Lou alisandra over the weekend
he was in the hospital all last week um
he thought he was going to try to make
it but his assistant uh gave me a buzz
and said that that's not going to happen
today so I let her know that this is
being live streamed that he could
probably view it if he's up to it so I
just want to let everybody know that
that's the only um other member that I
heard from that could not make the
meeting
today uh first order business is to
approve the minutes uh of the last
meeting um I'm I'm going to turn that
over to you uh representative Jan again
um but um do you want to handle
that does um yes thank you Mr chair does
everyone have the um yes they were
handed out okay and and they were
distributed ahead of time
okay all right um I guess does anyone
have any changes we a motion let's make
the motion move to
adopt Bry okay
Bry take a
second um okay does anyone have any any
uh changes additions
deletions no okay looks like
none no so I don't do you say all in
favor or do I say all in favor I'll do
it all in favor of uh the motion I
opposed no okay minut minutes are
adopted all right um we had given uh Mr
McIntyre um a list of things to to work
on and he's come through again um I have
some other embellishments I'm going to
do a little later on on on U on certain
things but uh Charlie do you want to
come up and I know you you brought us
the the glossery and things like that if
you want to just
explain actually one of the best things
about my job is I have folks to do this
too so um our folks put together a
glossery of terms um this is sort of the
vernacular of gambling in many respects
if you want want to go over them there's
more than this uh if you are interested
there are a number of websites that do
this uh I didn't think you all needed to
know what vigorish or cooler was um or
other terms like that so I I we edited
it out as as needed um but certainly
this isn't a bad way to start in terms
of understanding what difference between
handle and hold and and the equivalent
so um you know using good
health so this is something you should
bring to every meeting so you'd have it
in your back pocket so you can yeah
yes
yes about this um are
these are these um words these
references this these terms um used
consistently for the most part yes for
the most part mean there are a couple of
critical ones like uh gross Gaming
revenue and handle and um yeah and I
sort of sometimes have the impression
that some items are being subtracted by
and other places or not um would you
encountered that have you encountered
that I have actually to that point
um in Lottery World versus Cass say
Casino world will use terms differently
um and will manage them differently like
for example um when we say gross
wagering on lottery we would mean the
actual overall SE sales so when we say
Powerball sales we would say gross
overall sales would be say this year $57
million whereas that would be termed
handle in machines yeah so um other than
know minor differences in terms of our
businesses there's not that much
difference and at the end of the day if
you you're ever wondering uh Resa of
Ames you can just sort of look at the
way the math works like the obviously
there's a funnel effect to gambling it's
the top of the funnel and then how it
gets distributed down obviously
virtually every gambling game I can
think of prizes is the highest expense
and then from
there and these are
uh kind of linked to our
statutes the the definitions are
consistent with this what the definition
of statutes yeah and one of the
difficult things is that Hampshire laws
are sort of in some respects sort of old
right and that the word Casino only
appears as a house of ill Fame I think
uh In Like A Pill from 1827 or something
and so you there's no when I'm asked to
Define what a casino is we can't Define
it because the law doesn't Define it it
defines it as a triable gaming facility
so that's what we call it and I brought
that up last meeting that everybody's
calling their facilities not Char gaming
locations but they're calling themselves
casinos and that's something I think we
have to address eventually here in this
commission that are we going to we're
going to if they're going to call
themselves casinos I think we should
have it in the statute as casinos um but
that's that's for down the road uh the
one thing I was going to open with and I
uh was that what we got to do here is be
fair to everybody involved in this
whether it's the Charities the
facilities the state the players
themselves as well as the communities
and the communities has come up again
I've gotten some calls about that so uh
again we're going to be addressing all
the issues and over time we have a year
to do this and uh and we we'll get it
right okay all right so uh the third
bullet is uh the the revenue I had asked
Charlie the last time
uh Mr
McIntyre uh we we you gave us uh
actually allocations by percentage but I
thought it'd be and I I thought it' be
helpful if we had dollars assigned to it
to follow the dollar
to make it more real and and you did a
nice job of coming up with a chart here
uh that does that uh do you want to
explain the the chart sure it's rather
basic a break once again this is the
benefit of having folks who do this for
living that are far more talented than I
am this was from our compliance and
investigations division um a breakdown
sort of in three categories how the
revenues are distributed uh first
through poker tournaments how much funds
are collected from players essentially
that's through a rake
um table games uh that's the revenue
obviously that the house wins and is
split accordingly and the second page is
HHR Revenue
distribution um the total handle which
once again is the amount of wagering
activity and then how that split up um
between the operator the charity and the
state this is for a month one of the
reasons we we wanted to do a month is
because the revenues specifically to HHR
are accelerating um with a significant
velocity so um it would be an incorrect
number for last fiscal year because we
much much lower than the current run
rate would be for HHR
Revenue okay so uh people are going to
see that the game operators get 75% of
the commission yes um and that charal
organizations get you know
945 just for the month of September um
thousand and Lottery gets 1.7 million
now let's explain that to so that we all
understand that I mean that that
lotteries portion goes to oversight
correct can you explain that sure um the
oversight involved in charal gambling um
is not that expensive and so really what
this does is and I will also back out a
second a number of of our employees uh
with John cordi who's our chief
compliance officer manage other things
as well and so it would be a waste of
time to have a charitable
gambling Auditors and investigators
because they're in the same rooms anyway
investigating sports betting and Lottery
and the rest and so it's an overall
function that we manage through the
state budget process and so this just
goes as transfers education for the
state and so for example last year and
I'm sure chairman Lang will be happy
about this last year we were supposed to
transfer 139 million and we transferred
187 and so this literally just goes to
extra transfers to the state for
Education trust fund so after the
expense of of Regulation correct correct
correct and um so there's still a
reasonable amount going to the trust
fund yeah and so HHR is not like our
biggest Revenue source is still scratch
tickets it's around $50 million annually
profitability uh second I think last
year was sports betting at 38 million
and so those are our big sort of tent
pole things okay
yes on the Bott so the bottom left hand
side the 1.7 million that you have there
there actually two boxes that should go
underneath that one box is your expense
if there are any charge to HHR and that
and then second box is what's returned
to the education trust fund yeah well
exactly we don't split it up like that
certainly the the same folks who audit
will'll audit a a room or we'll audit um
a charity They Don't Really break out
how time they spent on HR versus how
much time they spent on games of chance
but certainly you're right there is an
expense there thank
you okay
so I'd like to focus on the the uh the
eight8 million for a minute now um just
this morning I got a I got uh an email
from the uh New Hampshire gaming New
Hampshire gaming uh charal gaming
operations
Association and they they produced this
for us um somebody from the association
want to just oh I think uh Aaron you you
want to explain this to us yes I could I
could walk you through it um so I think
the most important thing here is um the
difference between handle and revenue
right when you read a lot of press
nowadays and they're just ill informed
and they talk about the money coming in
the handle as if the operators are
taking that as Revenue that's not the
case at all right as you can see 90% of
all the money that's wagered goes back
to the player then 2 and a half% on HHR
Machines of that Revenue so 25% of the
revenue goes to the between the charity
and the state about
2.1% or 21% of the revenue um is towards
Labor uh roughly 2% uh goes towards the
HHR technology fees so when comparing
this to class three games like in
Massachusetts Maine they don't have have
the HHR technology fee so it's pretty
unique to uh to New Hampshire in the um
in the
Northeast uh about 2% go towards
marketing or advertising marketing
advertising in free play so that's uh
everything from tv ads newspaper ads to
free play to similar to coupons can you
explain free play please I'm sorry can
you explain for yeah so it's like a
coupon uh every every operator in New
Hampshire use it goes you mail it out
and says come in based on your historic
play it's a reinvestment so come in and
get $10 in free play so it's free slot
handle okay thank you um and then about
1.4% left over for the operator that
covers debt rent other taxes utilities
Insurance operating supplies and that's
what the company retains anything left
for profits and uh important to note
here this is not exactly ours it's not
exactly any other operator this is
General in terms of our experience and
and what we see so well the good news
here is that the handle on this
Charlie's for September is the same
handle here so the starting points were
the same yeah um but some people are
going to look at that 8 million and
still have some concern so how come
there's when they say there's 2.1%
Labor uh for for this but isn't the
machines of the machines you you the
technolog is being covered than another
bucket MH what labor are we talking
about here so that's everything from
surveillance to Auditors
to uh slot technician or sorry HHR
technicians to um it cashiers it's what
we have to spend to run the business but
are some of those things uh both for the
table games as well as the HHR that you
have you in the bookkeeping you split it
out that way uh correct correct yeah
right okay chairman yep no the 2% under
marketing advertising free play is that
take into account the statutory offset
for promotional uh yes correct so it's
still 2% even though you get to offset
promotional monies correct okay
yeah so I think again this is one of the
issues that the commission's got to deal
with is is is the in this chart is the 8
million a fair amount either way is it
the fair amount and that's something
that I think the commission is going to
be looking at down the road so
um okay thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you this 2.1% labor now is
that is that like um what you allow them
to spend and what happens if they're
over or under what happens with the
money that's either overspent or under
spent so who makes up for it they go
over are 2.1 so the labor is not
mandated by anyone that's just what on
average each operator as a percentage of
Revenue is spending on labor in their
business out of their abortion uh well I
guess you could say out of the revenue
correct okay and and that also goes for
the rent and other taxes and
everything sorry I'm not sure I
understand the question so what if what
if uh they get into a place with real
high rent that goes over the 1.4 with
the uh with all of these the rent and
the taxes and the insurance and
everything goes over the
1.4% that again comes out of the The
Operators so these are kind of rough
numbers like I mentioned certain of our
properties we own so we don't pay rent
certain properties we rent and we we do
pay rent right so these are kind of
averages if you look at the other oper
across the entire State um what
operators are are likely spending based
on our history and what we're spending
and discussions with other operators so
it's they're rough numbers my question
was this is adjusted out of the
operator's
income yes so that entire percentage
here 10% is the operator's income okay
and that's what all of these allocations
are coming out of okay thank you you're
welcome thank you yeah the the question
is the big big picture question is how
much is this one up profit to the to the
owners of these facilities and that's
what the public wants to know is it is
it a fair amount and the rest of it yes
we understand that there's a cost of of
a business there's a risk that they're
taking by opening a business uh but just
wanted to get a sense and down the road
we're going to be talking more about
this uh how do we get our hands around
around uh uh whether this is a fair
number that we've come up with uh in the
original legislation for HHR that's all
Mr L Aaron just to be clear so you're
really talking about 7.5% of the overall
hand of of the overall handle is what
you have to work with correct for
operating expenses of your gaming
operator and that may any given month
shift a little bit between these numbers
but you're still dealing with whatever
the handle is 7 and a half% of the gross
out of 100% right you keeping 7 a half%
and of that you have to divide all of
these models out in you know like your
HHR techi is probably pretty standard
right that's going to be a static number
game over game over game right for the
machine but other numbers like labor may
change or your your um you know your
marketing May adjust to deal with the
fact that you have higher labor costs in
a given month or if that correct yes
thank
you representative w i mean the
representative
Ames yeah I I have a couple of questions
but first uh who who did this this is
very helpful so that's first I want to
say that the association the association
that the New Hampshire Charter ball
gaming operators Association that's Rick
Newman and Alicia Preston okay Alicia's
here all right
um and then I'm I'm wondering if it's
possible uh to maybe we'll get to this
down the line but uh i' I'd like to see
a similar um display that relates
to slot machine based
Casino um like the one in central
Massachusetts in Plan F and how that
plays out I know the tax rates are
different but showing that whole thing
uh would be helpful I think well later
in the agenda we have one one and a half
million to one and a half million
150,000 to bring in Consultants to help
us out and this may be one of the ways
we we use them we'll have that
discussion later on
yeah does the uh amount here for that
the uh the operator
holds are they then charging rent to the
charity under
HHR um yes so as part yes that that
would not be included that would be in
other Revenue that'd be part of so so
shouldn't that basically be ented in
here in that the operator is getting a
addal dollars if you want from the
charity so that the charity is not cruly
getting part of that 2.5 if you want
that to set aside for the charity and
the uh and the state but I would say to
that technically we're not charging none
of the operator charging rent for
HHR okay we're going to have a long
discussion in a minute about about rent
rent is going to be the focus of today
the rent that they the Charities are
paying is is really the top uh thing
we're going to be talking about so we'll
hold that until until then okay but what
on your chart the one under the 1.4 when
you say rent you're talking about
renting the facility cost renting the
property right renting the property or
the debt would be you know the
amotization of of the if you bought it
okay so all right so uh any other
questions on
this now thank you Charlie it's a good
oh yes J yeah thank you Mr chair I just
had a question the so the 90% that goes
to the player that that's just is that a
rough number or is
that basically law of averages every
dollar that goes in about approximately
90% goes back some a little more some a
little less okay so then
um this isn't necessarily a question for
you then when I look at the example I
guess that U Mr McIntyre brought where
the total handle 121 million uh uh and
change and then the commission takeout
is 10 milon 811 is that what I mean I
just calculated it to be about 88.8% I
mean is
that is there an absolute number or
percentage that that reflects that
no so that number Al is also like an
average of what's happening
okay
okay overall for the current run rate
amount of gr giving Revenue be 130
Milli
okay okay
thanks
yeah you it okay um
I have one more question Charlie so
Charlie are we seeing and I know this is
early and you just talked about
accelerating rates are we seeing any
kind of ratio or any kind of change to
GOC for
HHR not yet but it's early and one of
the things is that we put into rule is
that there has to be a table to machine
ratio as well as a machine to table
ratio in terms of profitability uh and
there are some as I think I've told the
folks of this committee before we're the
last stop on the line so we keep hearing
rumors about massive facilities
elsewhere uh that we haven't seen yet
all we've heard is press reports and so
once those happen I'd imagine we'll see
a change it was certainly our ardan fear
is because the labor costs for table
games are much higher than machines they
just are um and the Charities obviously
do better with games at chance than they
do with his stor hor racing they get 35
cents in the dollar versus eight and so
our fear was that operators threw no
fault of the their own but certainly
with business motive would want have
machines and not do table games and so
um our fear is that will be they will
try to push the envelope that way
certainly operators have asked to wave
that provision a number of them have and
we've declined so it's our to your point
Senator it's a deep fear we have so the
concern again is that we're as as HHR is
expanded um we'll see games of chance
decline we has to stay equal now
but certainly I'm always fearful of what
I don't know so we have have we hit has
any any operator hit the ratio yet come
close come some have come close yes but
no none have hit it yet thank
you and can but to that point the
facility in Nashville which is alleged
to have 1,200 machines I do not know how
they do tables to the same ratio I just
don't not with the labor issues that all
of the operators have regarding dealers
and and staff it's just they just not
big enough
pool one more question yeah follow is
that ratio a monthly ratio or is that
just uh per day per charity how how's it
per uh it's I think it's if I recall
believe it's per my month per month per
month and then if they exceed it they
have to give the money to their charity
thank
you Charlie just for the committee can
you explain the fees to the third party
vendor um because unlike slot machines
the the the track owners are providing
all of these uh uh pre pre-run races
yeah uh and there's a certain fee that's
associated with that can you can you
just for the edification everybody here
can you explain that certainly if I mind
I'd like to refer this to our chief
compliance officer who deals with this
regularly okay I don't want him to
attend here without actually doing
something it's good having people to
it's wonderful having I'm telling you
it's the best it's the best in life I
thought I was going to escape but um
John 40 Chief compliance officer in New
Hampshire Lottery
um so you from our perspective as the
regulator what we understand is that um
The Operators obviously contract with
both game providers and then the
terminal providers um some of them
choose to lease that equipment um and
pay on a percentage basis on a uh
monthly some buy it obviously there's a
cost associated with that that I'm sure
gets amortised over time so um I'm sure
Mr goes could give you more specifics on
the uh you know on the equipment uh
expense with respect to that but um that
would be my understanding of what that
number is
representing yes you sorry did you want
me um so there's really two large
operators in the HHR space um system
wise so exact uh and answorth and the
general models I mean based on volumes
Etc like anything in in business the
more you buy the more you have the lower
those rates can go but in general if you
lease the product from them so you don't
spend the $220,000 per game you pay a
20% technology fee that can be
negotiated down if you put money up
front to buy the boxes you could get
that down to somewhere around probably
12% based on again volume and operator
so do most of the facilities uh lease
these machines or do they they purchase
them I guess you can speak to your fa
yeah I can I can only speak to us for us
were're we well capitalized so we buy
them generally um but I would say most
of the facilities across the state off
the top of my head would probably
especially the smaller ones would would
lease them right then when you buy them
is there a uh maintenance fee that you
pay it's at at least 20% 12% 12% that
you pay that's what you're talking about
there okay all right any other questions
on this one I just want to try to get
some of the stuff out early on so we
understand what we're talking about
again important distinction between
class three they have no ongoing fees
you buy a box and you put in or you
lease a box and you don't have the
ongoing fees like you do here when you
when you when you do the uh maintenance
fee they will Pro provide you technical
support if there's a
problem you pick up the phone you say
hey we got a and they'll go in from afar
and look into the machine and see what's
going on correct and they do have some
fees I believe it's called Equibase I
don't know you may uh that they have to
pay ongoing for the use of the
historical um horse races right that's
correct there's um the the data the
horse race data um is a separate
contractor that the uh toe providers
also have to pay to keep that database
uh updated um so that's um that's a fee
that's baked in and I think rolled into
the fee that the operators ultimately
pay yeah talk about the totalizer think
how that all works can I mean so there
goes maybe you're not the guy to talk
about this but so so there's some
central location where all these race
all prior races are are
held uh big database I would imagine can
you just talk touch on that yeah so the
totalizer is basically the system that
operates the the the game itself so what
what's happening on the terminal is a is
a um is software that is you know an
entertaining uh engagement but the
actual wager goes into a totalizer
totalizator um and that is where the the
um the the the system serves up these
historic hor races which determine the
outcome of the game so there that that
system takes the wager in calculates the
pool because as we're not one of the
differentiators between slots and
historic horse racing is it is
paramutual in nature so when you put a
dollar into a machine you're you're
you're you're betting into a pool um the
uh operator on the the the the revenue
that we're talking about gets taken out
as a commission or a takeout off the top
um and the remainder of that money goes
into a pool the totalizer then
totalizator then manages that pool
determines an outcome makes a
calculation of what the payment should
be um and sends that back to the machine
so um the you know the tote service
which as Mr glum said there are two
major ones and there's four total that
operate in the state that's really the
guts of the game um those are the
systems that really op at the game um
and the the the boxes and the game
software that sit on top of that um are
really more for uh entertainment and
engagement with the player but the toad
is what really operates the the the the
HHR so is the pool is the pool just that
facilities pool or is it a larger pool
than that no the pool is that facility
and there are pool there are games that
um that that pay into a uh into a pool
there has to be at least two um there's
usually more than two um our rules don't
forbid a sharing of pools across um
facilities but no one has uh has taken
us up on doing that as of yet is that
something we should discuss down the
road uh about you
know would you think we should I mean
right now it's not an issue because no
one's doing that but it sounds like
something we should discuss as a as a
group it it's certainly uh something
that the commission might be interested
in looking at it's it's from a
accounting perspective it's actually not
um terribly difficult because of the
nature of the takeout so if you're
sitting in Manchester and you you bet a
dollar that dollar that 10 cents is
getting taken out in Manchester um and
that 90 cents could go into a pool but
in terms of the accounting that the
division is concerned about with respect
to making sure the charity gets their
cut the state gets their cut in
Manchester because that's tied to a
specific charity that's taken care of
before we start going into the pools now
our accounting folks would look into
making sure the Shar pools are paying
out correctly but it's not it's not
something we're overly concerned about
from the lottery perspective at this
point in time and again right now The
Operators have just not um not sought
that but I think that's not necessarily
a concern that we have but so what
you're saying is the operators aren't
asking for this either not as of yet
we've heard that there might be some
interest in it in the long term but not
uh currently I remember years ago we we
dealt with this with Bingo right didn't
we do some kind of shared Bingo thing I
don't think it really ever took off even
though we passed the legislation for it
yeah I mean certainly I think most of
the folks in I could be wrong but I
think most of the operators are still
trying to get their feet wet trying to
get their feet under them operate right
create a player base Etc so okay I think
they're not worried about the next step
and that could be I would Mr goes would
probably
be
yeah I I just wanted to clarify I don't
think Mr conord is talking about sharing
amongst different operators it's if the
same operator owns multiple rooms so
there's no advantage to the operator it
would really be to the I guess marketing
your bigger jackpots the more people
that you have come in the only
disadvantage of the player you may see a
pool go down and it's not at your
location so it's somewhere else but it's
from operator perspective it we don't
gain or lose any more or less Senator l
so again currently they could do that if
they want to we regul there's no
legislative action that would need to
have to take effect the regulations
would allow it right now so so they
could if they wanted to for player
purposes have larger pools they could
combine and do that work if they wanted
them yes and it doesn't affect the
outcome of the state at all because we
take our 10% off the top before any any
player sees a dollar correct there'd be
no impact to the state or the charity
and last question just to make sure
clear when we talk about class three
machines and Slots those are the same
things right so again class three
machine the slot machine has no
technical end on it if you will that
database and expense to the operator
whereas historic horse racing does have
a technical expenditure to the operator
in order to maintain them I mean there's
still expenses to a class three machine
there's still a license fee there's
still the technical but you're playing
against the machine itself whereas
historic or raising you're playing
against the pool thank you right okay oh
representative hes yeah
so you got a hand and you've got a
takeout which is also called a
commission in our
statute um in our
statute the uh takeout slash commission
is up to
12% in fact according to this um it's
playing it's it's coming out at at about
9% um how is that engineered what you
know the amount of the T of the takeout
is less than what's Allowed by the
statute um both why and how I guess yeah
so first of all that 12% is a maximum so
there're certainly a permitted to go
under that um and so each uh game has a
math model associated with it which has
a takeout percentage and that's how they
structure the prizes knowing how much
money is going to be going into the pool
um so they do vary um between as low as
six and change up to 11 um and again
that's really all dependent on the math
model that's provided to us um we review
that just to ensure that it is compliant
with the um with the regulation um that
it doesn't go over the 12% um and but
everyone's math model is a little bit
different and obviously The Operators
pick out the ones that perform the best
for them um and we have tracked at about
nine and change for the the last say
four to six months I think that seems to
be the Sweet Spot of where operators uh
want to be and again that's that's in
aggregate individual games vary between
like I said that six and change and 1011
um we don't we haven't seen I don't
think anything as close to 12 on a
regular basis follow follow um have you
information about other states that have
historic horation I know there AR very
many but and how the uh the
takeout compares to
our relatively limited experience so
representive I would say it's it's
anecdotal but we do look at Wyoming and
and um I don't know that we've looked at
Virginia recently but I believe that the
101% is traditional in the other states
that we've seen so it's it's it's fairly
consistent uh with what we've seen in
New
Hampshire thank you okay all right
anything else on this for now just also
to add to what um John has said all the
machines all their math models are
tested by a laboratory and that
paperwork is submitted here before there
was things are allowed in the state so
um it's confirmed okay and you do mon
you do Mo obviously you're monitoring
the
percentages yes we we we literally get a
uh report from each to for each location
every day um and so our Auditors review
that every single day U make sure that
there's no um um issues that come up for
example we we we had a machine that was
misprogrammed and went at 12.5% we were
able to identify that immediately get
that rectified um so that can happen if
a software gets loaded in properly or
something like that because these games
will be have different math models they
could be they could be done under
different math models models um but we
do review those literally daily right
okay J again thank you so just to follow
up to that so I understand the 12% limit
so if and because it's a game of chance
if somehow even with the math model
there was an aberration and it hits
let's say 133% does that extra 1% just
or or then the the operator would have
to just adjust back down to 12% it it
should never be it's because it's not uh
this isn't a payout like it would be on
a on a slot machine it's a set takeout
that's always there it should be
programmed in correctly so it it within
each game it should always be what it's
what it was tested at and what it was uh
designed to be um so we don't get we may
get variance in wins or losses so the
pool may go up or they may go down
within a day but that takeout percentage
should not
change okay I see no other hands so
let's move on to the next agenda item um
there'll be more discussion about all of
this I'm as we move forward but um the
next one was uh
uh the uh list of Charities and the
money they made it was asked that we see
all the Charities uh that are involved
right now and a sense of the money that
was made so we have two sets of charts
that were given
us and they were by quarter looks like
they were by quarter oh no by
month
or some and then another set of were by
by
quarter I think
this there's one that has the Bingo and
Lucky Seven on it as
well and then there's charts that
have uh games of chance
yeah eron did you get this one's yours
from from The Operators group did you
provide this no we we didn't provide any
of sen we provided that okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry this that's and this is the
charity allocation is HHR and on on this
one that has the uh allocation the rent
allocation that's the gross of HHR end
um or is that just games a
chance I I think it depends on the
facility no I think Senator it's just
schemes of chance for the for the
quarter Le that we provided to you of
course rent isn't taken to maor char
that's right yeah right that's that's
the question I had too once we get going
on this
so uh is this just for our information
is someone want to discuss what's I
think it was informational I think there
was a question by a number of the
members to the variance between um which
facilities charge which levels of rent
some but there's no set
amount right other than it has to be a
commercially reasonable rent for a
property of that size in that given
jurisdiction I'm going to talk about
this in a minute I I have another hand
out myself that I did up over the
weekend so okay so this is just FYI the
the first set is in looks like alphab
alphabetical order of the Charities that
are
involved and it's just um just
the right it's just the table games not
HHR
correct this
one H that does have HHR too yeah so it
just shows this is all this is all the
revenue how it's broken okay and then
and then what the rent is but the rent
is is against just the games of
chance yes that's correct okay and then
the second set is uh is uh the four
quarters here uh that are shown
um and that that's again I want to make
sure that's when we say charity
allocation that's just from
the is that just from H from games of
chance I don't I have a feeling it's
both but though Mr chair I think the the
ones that are La labeled as quarterly um
right their charity quarterly charity
allocation and Rental payments yes so
there are four of those for um those are
for games of chance
alone um and then the obviously the
larger spreadsheet that is by month is
for all all Gaming revenue for by
charity
okay all right so I spend a little time
on this over the weekend which is a
dangerous thing um can you help me out
I'm want to hand these
out
keep one for the file
too so as I was saying that the main U
thing I want to cover today is is the uh
is the rent
payments and um
so first thing we we'll we'll start with
the top thing on this handout is the uh
is the actual
statute uh 287d colon9 facilities
rental the top part uh Roman Roman
one really is is for if you want to
uh not go one of these f locations but
want to have this has nothing to do with
the teral gaming locations we're talking
about is my understanding so it's it's
really Roman 2 that we're talking
about
and uh it says uh first says if a
charitable organization contracts for
services from a game operator employer
license under RSA 287 d8 the game
operator employer shall provide
equipment and shall not charge the
charitable organization for such
equipment okay cuz that's that's pretty
and I think they we're okay with that
that part of it then then it goes on to
say no charitable organ organization
shall receive less than 35% of the gross
revenues from any game of chance minus
any prizes paid and Rental charge under
of under the uh sub paragraph uh sub
paragraph B which is the next
paragraph and I think
uh
it it that appears to be what's going on
it's 35% is what's coming up these are
these are the games of uh games of
chance but then
B is if a gamer operative employee
charges rent son's charge shall be
written be by written agreement and
shall be fixed
payment not based on percentage of what
the charal organization receives from
the game a
chance uh and here's where I start
getting a little nervous
because uh I don't know if there's
really written
agreements um and I've spoken to two
Charities that claim that there's no no
written
agreements uh I had one that told me
that that boy we used to pay you know
$50 in random uh a day and now we're
paying you know $750 a day with no no
interaction and I had another charity
who said and they brought their contract
their agreement and I there was nothing
about renting it so uh but then it says
later on it says
um sh written
agreement shall reflect the fair market
then it says it shall reflect the fair
market value of the property for
use and that's a tough one I mean how do
we how do we how do we figure that out a
fair market value of the the rent now
now this all this statute it's all
before HHR machines so these table games
are in the same buildings as the HHR
machines matter of fact there's more
floor space that's HR machines then than
games a
chance uh then you go to C any service
or rental agreement entered into by the
charel organization shall be submitted
with the charel organization's license
after application for review by The
Lottery
Commission so the question becomes is
that really what
happens uh yes Mr chair it is um the
every charity has to have for games of
chance has to have a uh written contract
agreement we have a form agreement uh
that does absolutely address rent um and
goes on file and is reviewed and a
charity would not get licensed without
having one of those on file with the
commission so if a charity is indicating
that they have not signed an agreement
um I'm not sure how that would have gone
through our process I'm asking the
question yep um so I'm right so so in
that
agreement there's a fixed amount that's
agreed to there is a fixed amount that
is agreed to so the the form the form
agreement that the commission provides
has a blank space for the rent number so
that a a charity and room are free to
negotiate a rent uh number that is uh
obviously within the fair market value
um but they have to identify that number
for the commission so if you um any
charity that we have we would have an
agreement on file which would indicate
what the what the charity uh rent will
be okay so and and and this would be
signed by both the the the Char location
as well as the charity correct okay so I
will I'll go
back so to be clear when we talk about
fair market value we're talking about at
5,000 square feet of space What would I
be able to get if say I was hosting a
wedding for that night or something
other event and what would the nightly
cost be for that and then you establish
what that what that is for that area and
they can't exceed that number so Senator
that's what how we've interpreted it
obviously the language is uh doesn't is
not that specific but when we did an
analysis on fair market value um the
most analogous thing that we could see
was renting of event space for meetings
weddings parties th that that type of
event um and so we did an analysis by uh
by uh area of the state on what a fair
market value on event space would be and
obviously anyone who's ever had to uh
pay for a wedding knows um that can be
quite costly alth you phone and if if
the form that you talked about that is
provided by the CH by The Lottery
Commission to the uh charity has a
number that would exceed that fair
market value you wouldn't allow that to
go through we would not thank you
okay
so uh it' be helpful um if you can just
is it public can you share some of those
agreements with
us absolutely we can share that okay
just want to see that I I okay I'd
appreciate that so okay
yes I think one of the items again here
that there are contracts obviously
between the operator and the charity and
the charity is
basically you know again lack of a
better word here if you want this hell
hostage because basically goes over and
says okay here it is it's a you know get
$750 or $1,000 if you want a
day negotiations are very limited
because the operator can just say hey
this is what it is right and we're just
going to have another charity come in
for your for your 10 days so that it's
right this is what we're trying to
understand we're trying to understand
this is just historic you know actually
as I was going through numbers and I'm a
numbers guy and I cut I really start to
understand when when this all started
all these facilities were small weren't
really big places and we understood
there would needed to be protections
that the so that the the facilities
wouldn't lose money I understand that
now but but what you're going to see in
a minute is the sizes are way there's
still some small ones but there's a
bunch of big ones too and those in the
middle so I I I think this part of the
statute needs to be really worked on I I
I was on w means for 12 years I never
really I always heard charity but never
really investigated what what that was
and I always thought it was like a flat
number that everybody PID
but no it's up to the individual instit
uh location to choose what they think is
fair uh but then is that fair to the
charity I don't know that's something
we're going to have to address but uh
what I did over the weekend if you go to
the scribbling the next two pages I took
the I took the numbers from
um I took the numbers from the
um the quarterly reports and I tried to
group them under the each each charity
and I did one more thing if because if
you go to that and I lost where's my
copy of
this where's the
um the
these so you'll see in the F if you take
a look at these guys these these charts
here uh you'll see in parentheses the
number of days that they're open okay
because I wanted to really see what the
rent was by facility per day per day
meaning the day that that they're
open and that the charity is sponsoring
so I had I went through the numbers and
you can
see the uh column to the it's little
hard to read because I was doing this
quick charity charity days and then rent
per day and the uh the rent per day is
based on the rent the rent
column so you'll see like Casablanca
Lakes Region they're small they they're
probably 12th out of the 13 that we had
data for in terms of size based on only
only generated
269,000
$500 in rent or 42% rent if you go
through these you're going to see the
rents ranging from 5% all the way to
50% okay that's number one all over the
place but actually I've come to
understand when you see this other chart
that I have that maybe the smaller
places actually had to charge more
because that because of their
size uh and to hold these events and all
that but we we'll talk more about that
but then I wanted to see because I'm
looking from the CH charitable
organizations uh charal organizations
perspective as well as the uh facility
uh game operators
perspective so so it looks like I'm not
picking on Casablanca here I'm just
saying that they looks like they charge
around
475 a day then you go down to wonder
casino and they're like middle of the
pack about eight one Wonder Casino uh
which is also in
conquer um it looks like before this is
where
uh here here's here's a phenomenon you
could tell from the days 92 days one
quarter 60 days another then 155 and
then 175 in the last two
quarters that tells me that uh and those
days included two
Charities so we have now we have two
char Charities paying rent for the same
facility which is another issue even
though even though there HHR machines
are not included in the
numbers uh but it looks like uh those
facilities that have char historic
racing there's two Charities not one and
you can see from these
numbers it looks like somewhere halfway
through they were they just had
um uh jamic chance but then they they uh
they they
had uh uh historic racing as well
because it was well
above uh the number of days in a quarter
that would be just one one
charity so but then what happened there
was then they then they they didn't
change the rate per but there's two but
they're getting uh uh well they did they
actually reduced they cut cut it in half
basically so that's fine if you go to
Dover Poker Room uh they're at
38% and then they were they were
charging 250 a day but when they got
historic racing machines that that went
up to like 750 a day I don't know
why uh then I have Boston Billiards they
were around 500 a day and then it
dropped down to 250 a day okay maybe
recog that there were two now because
you could tell that there's now historic
racing there now from these numbers if
you keep on going down the list you can
see um um the Granite State Poker
Alliance which is in Manchester they
were charging around 500 a day and now
they're charging 750 a day but times
two so uh then you have smaller rooms
like um well no the interesting one is
is chases which is one of the biggest so
the second amount of revenue of any of
them and they didn't change it they have
they don't have historic racing machines
they're at basically 90 days a quarter
and it's about
$500 across the board but the
the uh then you go down to Lebanon poker
room um again they have they looks like
they picked up historic racing machines
about halfway through this this this
fiscal year uh and the rent went down uh
from 250 to 125 you can see it's all
over the place per from the from the
Chari perspective how much are they uh
per day are they taking in being rent uh
having to pay
rent uh and I can keep on going through
these but the smallest room the
interesting thing is that the smallest
room which is Northwoods
Casino has the has the lowest rent they
don't have historic racing machines
they're charging 14 47 on the average
probably 150 is their target but
whatever
reason but when you put the charity days
against the rent it really starts
showing you what we're what we're
dealing with so if you flip to the next
page I summarized this for you I went
from the I took the annual dollar
charity
allocation and they're ranked in terms
of that from top to bottom so the brook
has 3.7 Mill do in charity
allocation uh big time money all the way
to North uh Northwoods Casino which is
106 729
176,000 and then I have what the rent is
and I have the
percent uh of the allocation and you can
see the bigger places have a smaller
allocation 7% 5% 5% fortimo is 14% and
then the the conquer Casino has the
highest of
50% um but when you so that's looking at
it from the
uh um from the facility standpoint but
from the from the charity standpoint the
last column is what is actually being
subtracted from their allocation per day
and that
ranges from
$147 a day Northwood casino but I just
me
mentioned up to filamin Phil filimo up
to 671 a
day uh there's no consistency here um at
all and I think this is one of the
reasons that we need to uh spend some
more time on this and then on the bottom
I put a little thing that's saying that
if I put a little a next to it it
appears that there um they're still just
table games only a b means in
parenthesis means that's the table games
plus HHR happen somewhere in
there uh well like the only one that's
that's a b is is the brook they've had
it from the numbers it looks like
they've had it the whole year and then
anybody who's a c basically it looked
like somewhere halfway through the year
they put the historic racing machines in
so which means that there's two
Charities that are paying the rent now
so I'm pointing these things out as as
discussion points for us as we go on
then I then I charted it it's always
good to see a
picture if you go to the last two pages
the one you you could see you could see
the the uh annual allocation as against
the
rent and you can see uh the highest is
is conquer
casino and the least is um Boston bards
and some of the others there uh grouped
if I took the if I took the top four
number out it's pretty much a straight
line in terms of percent from the size
uh but we looks but it looks like it's
kind of an exponential kind of a thing
going down um from there but when you
look at the last chart which is rent per
charity day versus charity
allocation there's really no rhyme to
reason um it looks like it's just
scattered everywhere uh so I guess what
with that basically the numbers are
showing me
that uh if we if we keep rent we need to
do some work about how do
we um how do we do this and there
there's some activity in the house
looking to do away with
rent um we'll see where that goes U when
the session happens next beginning of
January retain
bill um but I want to open this up to
discussion I I I I think that U Senator
Lang no again I'm just a little I'm
trying to look at your
number the two things that strike me is
number one location location location
right so a cost of a room in Nashville
is going to be different than a cost of
a room in Belmont because again what the
average fair market value is for a given
room is going to be adjusted and changed
size Matters right so again depending on
the size of facility the amount of rent
you charge for the size of the facility
is going to make a difference I'm not
sure how we know aliz that data into
what is a fair market value estimate um
somehow Lottery is able to do that um
obviously if I only have a 2,000 foot
room versus a 5,000 foot room I'm going
to get a different rent and but the rent
should still be the same per day for a
given facility anyway may not be between
the facility in Belmont and the facility
in NASA but the rent is still all of the
rent charged in NASA is going to be a
same amount per charity assuming they
have a fixed contract I don't know we
talk to the operators and see if they
negotiate different for different
charities or every charity pays the same
amount but again I'm not sure how you
normalize that when you're dealing with
location and you're dealing with size um
amenities what you offer and what you
don't offer is free Wi-Fi no free Wi-Fi
what is included in that rental charge
that they have access to so I don't know
how you would normalize that data other
than what Lottery's already doing by
saying a 500 foot facility in nashille
is worth a th000 bucks a day well from
the can't exceed that number from the
first chart it looks like it's it's
happening by itself that that yes the
bigger places and these are the big the
three down that the right hand corner
there that are in the 3.5 million
range have have a have the smallest
percent of the allocation going to them
from a from a facility location it
doesn't mean that they're the lowest
rent though because when you go to the
the last chart that isn't the case
they're more in the middle uh are the
high end of the middle so the question
becomes well why is that
why do they even need if you're a big
facility and if we're comparing
ourselves
to let's call them Vegas Times casinos
there's no such thing as rent uh do we
really need rent uh is the bigger
picture question uh I think it's one we
have to address and I I tried to put
some more data around this to to to show
it and to show and then the other thing
is that with the historic racing one
thing I didn't know going into this
meeting was whether in the in the
allocation whether the historic racing
uh money was in there as well and it
sounds like it isn't so uh but these
places once were getting one rent now
they're getting two rents for the same
facility so that's something we have to
address uh because the statute hasn't
changed since the you know about eight
nine eight years
ago um where historic racing machines
didn't
exist um so I I just think of is
something we have to have to deal with
as a as a commission on this on this
topic so is anybody else want to discuss
it nope
okay how do the charity Representatives
feel about
this um so I also work at Boston buer
club now Gates City casino and I'm on a
couple boards as well so the way we I
can only speak to that one location we
used to when we did games a chance
charge a flat rate of 500 per day that
fell in the percentage we're obviously
large we have larger
expenses when we ended up having two
Charities benefit we split that fee
between the two with the tiered system
if you're a tier one which all it means
you're a charity that benefited in
2020 if you're paired with the tier two
the tier one gets preference per the
legislation they get 100% of games a
chance and half of HHR so if you're
paired with a tier 2 they would pay that
whole 500 where the tier 2 only
benefiting from HHR wouldn't pay
anything if you have the same tiers the
we try to pair the same tiers together
just so it's fair but that's just that's
our location if you pair the same tear
together they split it so they each paid
the 250 so rather than doubling the rent
we just split it in
half okay yeah so but I'm not sure of if
is everybody else doing it the same way
you're doing it see what I mean it seems
like I understand I would I would have a
sense that
it's we've left it up to the facilities
to make the rules if they the road if
you will I'm I'm sure it varies just
because it's just structured that you
can I mean certainly As I understood the
basis for rent it was what a time when
the operators were struggling right and
now the current run rate for St horse
racing is to exceed $100 million in
Revenue so rent doesn't seem like it's
needed
anymore so I mean let's use Boston
billage you say that's where you your
Boston billage so the so the allocation
to charity 3.5 million doesn't include
the HH HHR
money um
and so that's 35%
so I mean the other 65% it makes it you
know it's you know over10
million so this is a big business this
is not this is not um I might be
misinterpreting but I thought this did
Charlie could speak to it maybe I
thought it did include
HHR no which there's two of them there's
two charts this one doesn't this came
off the quarterly
vertical apologize pulled off these I
pulled these and and handwritten off of
the the quarterly reports yeah okay
because that's the only place that had
the number in parentheses it had the
days each of the
Charities
participated okay and then once the
Charities once those days went over 365
I knew that there was historic racing
somewhere along the line um because
that's how many days there are so
uh fun question yeah can I'm sorry I'm
going to apologize here I'm going to go
backwards a little bit tier one versus
tier two so Charlie can you describe
that for us so way every understands of
course so with the Advent of store horse
racing
um it would take a while to get up and
running and so when the facility did
indeed start doing historic horse racing
they would have to have now two
Charities but um it was impressed upon
us that we didn't want the Legacy
Charities which would be the tier ones
which had been in child gambling prior
to HHR to lose out essentially and so
that there would be a phased in process
by where we'd have two tiers tier one is
the Legacy Charities would have the
80% PR 2020 any charity prior to 2020
let me the numbers no the tier ones um
would get all of uh I believe all of
games and chance and half of HHR and
then the tier 2 would only participate
in HHR the thinking being obviously that
tier tws that would be all new money for
those Charities um so while it would be
an uneven split um the tier two
Charities would uh be new participants
in and obviously it be new money to the
charity and that runs through I believe
January this year yeah so so in January
this year you will you may have Legacy
Charities which now have to split evenly
with another charity and they their
money will may go down but may go up it
certainly with the it just depend on the
room and and the facility yeah but to
G's point I think I know she speaking
only as to Gate City um but I think our
experience now is that most operators uh
pair like siiz tiers together uh ones
and ones and twos and twos so that it is
an even split uh more often than not
just confirming that yes that is correct
um so um although they had the ability
to sort of um grandfather in the older
Charities what has happened is that
they've um I think probably to to manage
Charities um they're they're tearing
them together so they're each getting
the same check um so although we had
that system in place it's it's the
operators have have sort of decided to
to to move forward and from what I
understand um because there's been
substantial growth in HHR and then
there's been growth in in games of
chance as well because of the $50 bet um
I I don't know that Charities are are
making the same as they did uh before
but it's probably relatively close and
obviously The Operators would have a
better sense of
that thank you so I'm just trying to
understand be clear so tier one tier the
tiers are going away essentially as of
January one of this year of 23 or as of
24 so January 1 the tiers go away and at
that point all if you have two Charities
involved they'll get they just split all
the Gaming revenue for a given day
50/50 yes that is correct thank
you so our numbers our our our metrics
are going to shift potentially that
we're looking at now because we're
looking at data that doesn't isn't
allocated that way for
Charities so so Senator Lang potentially
you're going to see a data shift but
more likely it's going to be a very
minor data shift because as I was saying
the game operators are essentially
operating as they would have to do after
January 1 anyway they are putting the
same tiers together which means a 50/50
split so I think we're living in a world
where
essentially we have 50-50 split of
Charities regardless thank you Aaron I
want you to chime in Aon what's your
facility again uh so we have Dover uh
Manch currently operating Dover
Manchester Lebanon um Keane as well as
Northwoods right which one is Kean Keane
is Wonder Casino Wonder okay
right so you you have facilities of all
sizes here correct I mean okay
so yeah again my thinking is that you
know historically we we protected this
because they all started as small when
this all
started and we protected them and maybe
there was a reason for that and I I
could actually understand that um you
know I look at Northwoods and I you know
which which one is your smallest one
Lebanon uh Lebanon probably leanon with
HHR yeah and the and the Lebanon Lebanon
yeah so
uh you
know I'm trying to get a sense of if we
did away with
warrant again I'm a little concerned
about the smaller places that they may
need some up protection a little bit if
if they they're open they open their
thing but no one shows up or it's it's
bad and they have the
expense uh but the larger places I don't
think that's going to happen um and that
if we if we modified the
rent um this wouldn't be a big an issue
just I need I need an
operator's perception look I could talk
specifically about us but I'm here on
behalf of the operators but if you look
at what we're paying on rent we own
currently the property under one of our
locations the rest we rent all the rent
we collect is less and we pay in actual
rent for the space um so it it's not I
mean it is that there's a market value
that's probably as close as you're going
to get to that and that doesn't include
the investment that that we have put
into the
properties but you're also making money
on the correct on the on the correct
play I mean isn't like it's all supposed
to go correct yeah thanks Mr chair I and
I think the testimony we've heard in
testimony we've heard over the years was
the survivability of the model initially
uh survivability of The Operators and
the Charities themselves back in the day
of two and four bets I think we've we've
uh grown far from that and um and I
think it's something dime to Donuts we
need to uh to look at and and and
dismiss I actually have uh an amendment
that Ways and Means is going to hear on
Wednesday day that addresses this it
eliminates there's some cleanup language
I have to do to the amendment so we hit
every paragraph in
287 uh and to back that up I have
another LSR in place I think we've we've
far grown past the point where we need
to be having the Charities pay a rent
for a space that is profitable for all
involved uh it's not about the
survivability of the the model anymore
so again all these facilities aren't
equal they are big big and they're small
small I mean and that's what we're
talking about so we got to be careful
how we handle us if I could sort of when
you characterize big big I think
Foxwoods and so you sort of if you look
in the sphere yes there's a facility
that's the largest in the state and then
there's the smallest in the state right
but as I've said before all of them told
together don't equal twin members so
just sort of for the record I I worry
adjectives which are sort of I don't
want to say inflammatory but certainly
no
no headline driven thank you for that of
course so again it ranges from 106,000
to the Charities to 3.7 million to the
Charities uh you know even even within
this range of size facility perhaps one
size doesn't fit all is what I'm getting
at so um but it sounds like the legisl
is already looking at this uh so we'll
dis monitor that but um
again this is your data was very helpful
to me to to extract which this to to get
a sense of what what the actual rents
are and again I find very interesting
that this the one off with the lowest
rent per the charity is $147 was the
smallest facility so somehow they're
surviving and now it could be that it's
a very low rent location
I'd say we're barely surviving until we
move the location so oh is that one
worse that's Lebanon is where we're move
we're moving to a new spot okay
so all right all right any other
discussion on this topic all
right all right then
um okay the next item is funding of
communities with charitable ation U with
a chable um that's what the things
basically funding
communities I I've gotten several calls
from communities uh people
saying uh why AR why AR the communities
getting uh some of this um some of the
profits if you will of these
facilities um we know when we had when
we heard years ago um charity uh uh
Casino bills you know Vegas style Casino
bills uh there was always provision in
there that the facilities would get uh
compensated for the extra police and so
forth so
on uh I don't think it was originally
contemplated because these were all
small now they're growing into on our
world New Hampshire
scale uh they're growing um and I I I
would imagine this is something that we
as a group should be discussing uh
Charlie did you you have a com on this
your name no it's just as I've said I
think if I haven't I apologize um every
every town or city we visit it's either
the first or second question we get is
we're having to host this what what's in
it for us and certainly the the fear of
sort of additional Services by the city
or town that are not compensated right
I'm not saying anything bad obviously
we're all in you know I'm in gambling
for a living so um it's not it's just an
additional Services may be required in
Cedar Town and funding for those
Services would be very much appreciated
by those communities is this um common
practice um I mean it seemed like it was
this big a point of discussion when we
talked about these um you know big Vegas
companies cominging in and yeah you know
during the original Casino bill that
representative Ames and I worked on a
commission back in 15 13 13 um I believe
it was the host Community got 3%
of the revenues from the facility and
then each surrounding Community split 1%
if I recall correctly I could be wrong
on that but I think that's right is so
if for the city of say Manchester
Manchester would get 3% of that
facilities revenues in the surrounding
communities would split 1% um of that
facility's take
right my only my only comment there is
they are paying property taxes these
facilities too to be sure to be sure
right and that sort of that number
varies by like for example um I know
like plane ridge for example is required
to do an minimum investment of 100
million I think and Encore was 400 or
500 million and so it there's very
there's vared ways to sort of make the
facility be a community partner right in
that respect right so it's common
practice yeah yeah yeah I mean certainly
in the newer facilities yeah ones sort
of the Vagas that are um
grandfathered in from decades ago
centuries ago no but now it's common
okay so again as as we do our work here
um I guess we have to
start thinking about whether you know at
the end of this process we're going to
have
recommendations and we have to and we'll
be voting on those recommendations okay
as individual recommendations as we go
along so we we need to talk more about
that uh if everyone one thinks that this
is something that the legislature should
take up our report's going to be report
of recommendations it's really up to the
legislature to take those up if they so
choose uh but it's recommendations that
we think uh you know we're pausing here
we have a year to do our work which the
legislature doesn't have that kind of
time and that's why we're paused and
we're we're looking at all of this and
uh you know some of the facilities are
getting bigger again on our and then New
Hampshire
scale um and and yes they probably are
looking
for well let me back up one other
step you know when we did Kino Kino
there's nothing to do with security but
it's has to do with um the town voting
to have a facility we did historic
racing that issue was brought up but I
said no no this is adding a game to an
existing facility
uh but we don't have op an opt-in or an
opt out provision for any future
facilities I don't think we could adopt
one for existing facilities or existing
facilities so that's going to be another
topic uh that we have to address uh
going forward if something we we want to
do for any additional facilities as well
as how many facilities um do we think we
can
handle uh there might be a diminishing
return in terms of um you know there's
only certain population that's going to
play these games anyway so uh but that's
another one um but in that bigger
picture conversation this whole issue of
supporting the
community uh would I think needs to be
involved so di yeah um this discussion
of funding for communities with
locations with game rooms um that have
uh raises the point points to the need
that we have
um as we have it as well with the
allocations
of of um ultimately the handle uh than
the takeout um but particularly the
takeout um and whether what we've got in
place right now and the statute is right
or should be tweaked it points to the
all these things point to the need for
um good information about what other
states are doing that have had different
kinds of experiences sometimes in the
case of historical horse racing much
longer than us ours and I think we can
learn a lot uh you mentioned playing
field uh Charlie mentioned planfield and
uh uh that's next door to us um that's
relatively new I don't know how many
years now five six years something like
that planfield
uh that
much
yeah they were yeah yeah okay anyway the
point is that there's good information
out there uh
Massachusetts is not New Hampshire uh we
all know that and so forth Maine is not
New Hampshire but Maine also has
experience that we need to get to inform
us as we make judgments for ourselves on
how to make an allocation for the
expenses the communities are incurring
taking into account the property tax
revenues will also be coming in all that
kind of thing um the more information we
can get get and the more help we can get
from this consultant that uh we're going
to hire to to do that for us is uh is
just welcome and and necessary for us to
do a good good
job so Charlie again if I could I guess
the first question I had is as to a
consultant is what do we want well
that's an agenda item to talk about yeah
I don't know if you we're getting there
it just before you do that so this is
another document that was handed out to
us and it does you want just going
through this with us real quick sure and
certainly it's it's a breakdown of
essentially
All State legislatively authorized
gaming specifically machine
gaming in New England those facilities
where they
are and certainly an overview of the
activity itself in the state and the
numbers involved so that's certainly
what this is for is last meeting I
suggested I think I was asked or i'
offered to do a breakdown of the numbers
of other Estates and what their Gaming
revenue looks like and so that's what
this is
um most notably Connecticut is not on
here because Connecticut is actually
tribal gaming which is an entirely
different category um it's not State
authorized it's federally authorized by
the Indian gaming regulatory act so um
Charlie I did this for a point point of
reference in terms of the numbers the
facilities how how large they are what
licenses fees they have to pay what the
take what their percentage they have to
pay to the state etc etc can you let's
go to main facts sure this
page yep can you just walk through that
table as to what these numbers
are um sure so certainly uh this is
Maine's calendar year 2022 so this slot
machine game gross Gaming revenue is
essentially the money that's left after
payment of
prizes um if I recall corre
correctly um Hollywood pays a 39% share
to the state and Oxford pays
46% uh for slot machines for tables I
believe it's
15% so the gross gaming rep this table
ggr is what's left after payment of
prizes and then the taxes obviously
taking into account that um labor costs
and surveillance and security for
physical tables is much much more
expensive um
and those numbers are reflected on table
taxes what goes to the state and then
what the total gross Gaming revenue is
for those two um functions and then what
the state's take is so in calendar year
2022 um Maine from Hollywood Casino in
Banger received 24 million and Oxford
they receive 44 million Oxford being
within driving distance quite easily
from the Hampshire border if I um maybe
five years ago I had a staff member
visit the Oxford facility in Oxford and
count license plates it's about the best
way to figure out what the revenue is
from New Hampshire and it's about one in
five cars and Oxford was from New
Hampshire so I assume one of that
Revenue to be our
citizens so you're saying that between
the two Oxford and Hollywood that the
state of Maine got $68 million
correct okay and then the next page
relates to the fees involved and the
number of fees associated with um the
activity yeah maybe we want to spend
some more time on this why don't we all
take a look at this and maybe next
meeting we could we could use we have a
little more of a discussion around this
sure u m um my counterparts in Maine
don't run the casinos the there's a
casino control board in main that runs
it okay and their own by I know the
facility in Oxford is owned by Churchill
Downs right and I don't remember who
owns Hollywood to you know it's uh pen
entertainment pen ENT okay pen pen yeah
pen does okay okay all right this would
be very helpful I think yeah just yeah
it's just a comparator in terms of what
other states are doing and what they're
receiving yeah so what we want to do is
again let's let's now talk about the uh
we have the 150,000 um
uh that some of that is going to a
consultant uh of our
choice uh what I think we need to agree
upon as a commission here is what are we
looking for in a consultant what we're
looking for regulations proper or the
allocation dollar allocations proper we
have to kind of agree on um what we want
out of of Consulting before we can then
I
Charlie and I met um to talk about this
um offline and uh there there's choices
I don't know you have names of
Consultants that we could
use um but we need he needs all the
guidance as to who we send the rfps out
to and what we
say and the other thing is I'm assuming
that this is a bid situation but maybe
not yeah chairman um certainly it would
be remarkably helpful for us to have a
scope of work from this Commission
right um I would have to bid it out it's
not particularly long period I had been
informed this morning by our CFO that I
would need
to the we would need to go to GNC for
its approval as well and so that process
adds time and so the sooner we can sort
of think of a scope of work the better I
don't know if you want to Appo a
subcommittee to create a scope of work I
guess I'd first like to ask the
membership as to what you hope a
consultant or Consultants would do
because certainly there's a number of to
topics you could delve into one is
economics one is sort of Regulation
governance all all manner of things so
um you know I leave the open question to
the
body so dick I know you have some stuff
you want to say on this but maybe
not well I can't do a
list I can't do a list as I said here uh
by a long shot um but um as I said we
need information about what other states
are doing this is a start right here but
uh sort of
a Step Beyond that would be what a
consultant would allow sort of the wise
uh and the context for the decisions
made in massachusett Maine Kentucky
Wyoming where there's historic horse
racing um getting a good look at that in
relationship to our starting point with
our historic horse basing machines and
our charal gaming unique
situation and that history putting it
all together is what a a consultant
could could do for us providing that
additional context from each of these
states but I I you know question doing a
scope of work is what you're after I
understand that makes sense um and I
guess we've got to work on that as soon
as possible because time the clock TI
and the uh approval process is uh it's
just takes
time well maybe a subcommittee is not a
bad idea just to um I guess we have to
do things in public though to do
that
um just point of clarification if
there's subcommittee is less than a
membership Quorum does it have to be
public I'm not that I'm I'm trying to
not be transparent obviously the scope
of work would be public document but I
know the answer to that question I think
I think everything we do is public okay
so um so
um um I think we need
to Charlie I mean I would certainly
volunteer Mr chairman if you want to
point a sub committee I'll certainly
volunteer to be a member of
it um I'll be a member who else who else
would be member we got okay Aaron
red me
Charlie anybody else
G um anybody
else
okay all right we'd have to meet next
week week
then so and I'd have to get in the
calendar and get a room yeah so we you
meet in my office conference room it'll
be open to the public yeah okay if
that's okay with everyone yeah right I
don't want to dictate to people but
certainly my office is available no we
use the conference room so it's public
people yeah exactly it's a signing sheet
K good
okay all right what's
today Monday right it's a Monday right
so yeah we can get in the calendar in
time to meet next week all right very
good so that that'll resolve that and
then the other question was on the
budget that you had there was money
for uh newsletters and other
things and I think the group said yeah
we we should spend some of that money on
on some
Publications is that do you have
specific ones that you would recommend
Charlie well certainly the first was the
it's item nine on the agenda um the
the na uh National Council on
legislators with gaming States I think
it's that's the it's called nickel G's
that's it's an acronym um we actually
submitted that for approval for um
budgeting for membership okay and that
kicked back to us by admin services that
we do have to go to GNC as well for that
um so we have to go to GNC so that means
you Mr chairman yeah no problem okay um
I'm happy to attend with you if you want
yeah okay so just as a question because
it's while it's this body it's coming
out of our budget not that it's our
budget but it's this commission's budget
but it's certainly a a unit under the
lottery budget but there there's good
data in this yeah yeah no exactly
there's it's a membership we belong to a
number of groups uh North American
lotteries World Lottery Association
Tri-State so it's a membership
organization to learn more about gaming
and access their resources and what's
the what's the annual membership
$5,000
okay you do have that budgeted right
correct like yes um I submit I I think I
set the budget around last time yeah you
did and I'm trying it's in my pile here
somewhere I was trying to find it but
yeah I know we did yeah so all right why
don't we do this oh here it is
Consultants was uh 10,000 10 oh no the
Consultants was one thing the membership
membership fees was the 10 ,000 so I
guess probably Mr chairman I best to
this body to vote for approval of this
yeah that's what I want to do right now
okay so
uh someone want to make a motion to
approve uh the National Council of
States uh
membership 5000 yeah let's let's approve
the money is it well if we get to
specific then it if it's for Mar at 4,99
and I would just suggest we approve
membership in the yeah it is submitted
as an invoice for 5,000 but they may
change so okay all right I need a
second
okay thank you all right so any
discussion excuse me thank you Mr
chairman aren't people from the house
already going to this
I don't think so I think they've gone to
it I don't think we're members I think
because I've checked the I checked the
website maybe two weeks ago and our
state wasn't a
member okay all right so I I because
we've are we've
been yeah Kelly's been in contact with
their office and so I don't they'd love
us to be
members okay okay so no other discussion
okay all in favor say I I all opposed no
okay we'll move forward with it and just
keep me posted on the uh GN whatever see
yeah all right
um all right I think that's the agenda
for today
um let's talk about the next
meeting I'd like to get two more
meetings in before Christmas if we can
just to keep this moving yeah Mr
chairman yeah just for future meetings
anyway here okay is um basically
addressing the what I we call the
in-house advertising for the you know
for the Charities again because I
visited several of the uh of the large
gaming houses appalled that the only the
only place if you want that the that the
charity is mentioned is on the license
you know it's next to the uh
cashiers it's a it's something that
basically again we're we're putting up
part of the money through the rent uh
that it's again I think that can be
fairly inexpensive if you want in these
facilities to at least have that yeah
this is the uh friends of of legislature
it's friends of dogs if you want okay
that are sponsoring this and uh at least
put it into people's mind a little bit
because that's that's the non monetary
if you want okay uh ability to go over
and at least connect with these eyeballs
that are in there right okay we'll
discuss that I I've been to some
facilities that do like we CH earlier do
public
the chat they supposed to let me ask you
the question we supposed to it it has it
has to be conspicuously
posted if you couldn't find it that's
not
conspicuous okay it's We Will We Will We
it's something that's on our
investigators uh list when they go into
a facility but we'll make sure that we
emphasize that
okay all right so I'm looking at now
Thanksgiving is early everybody gets you
know you know it's we still have a whole
week after Thanksgiving that's
November I was looking at maybe Thursday
November
30th me it's Monday morning a good day
for everyone I don't want to do it I
don't want to do it the Monday right
after Thanksgiving because people are
probably still traveling home from
wherever they may be going that weekend
yeah I mean the 30th I'm trying to keep
it to Mondays especially during
legislation season where there least
amount of stuff going on as a
Monday but since legisl is not in right
now I'm thinking that it'd be okay for
legislators if we did it on a Thursday
or
I or Friday that week
yeah is there a way to do it two-way
digitally so if members can't make
it uh well right now the this is being
streamed but it's not a two-way stream I
could talk to the tech people but Mr
chairman we could do that to my
office we have two-way stream if you
want and under the law the quum only
counts is five and so five are
physically here if members are away
there'd be no violation of the open
meeting you know the
Quorum I'm actually away that week but
if we did have you know ability to phone
in or or video in whatever I could do
that okay we could do it with Lottery we
Prof from just to Tech certainly um we
have a smart TV and cameras so yeah I'm
making promises from RT department so
they'll have to they have three weeks to
figure it out because I originally
thinking that we should meet at lottery
for all our meetings but because of
um Senator de Sandro's you know
physical limitations now I thought it'd
be kind of hard for him to go over there
and get a ride back you know although we
could probably arrange it to to pick
them up and and go over there so um so
why are we okay so you can't make that
date huh either those I'll be out of
state yeah anybody else can't be here I
can't make the 30th I'm book solid that
day how about the how about the Friday
the Friday um the next day that'll be
the first
yeah um anytime after 11:30 in the
morning all right so that'll be one
clock meeting I can't be here that week
but I could be digitally as well right
two can't be there that week all right
why don't we why don't we just step to
the next week
um that would be December the week first
full week of
December we do it the 4th the Monday the
four December 4th same time 10 o'clock
yeah try to keep it 10 is that all right
everybody okay
okay I guess we could stay here um it
will either be in this room or back at
the state house if we can get the bigger
room in the state house and did you want
to do two before Christmas Mr chairman
that was my goal but um I don't know
we'll talk about it next time we'll talk
about the next date
um then Christmas comes up we got to
stay away from Christmas
week maybe just the 18th is two weeks
after the
fourth what what you say the 18th 18th
the 18th is yeah we could probably do it
the 18th it'll be two weeks but why
don't we tentatively say the 18th for
the okay second one saying the next
meeting December
4th you good okay all right now let us
back to the room
again I'm trying to think of Lou if Lou
can't make it maybe it'd be better to do
it in lottery so he can he
can can dial in I I like I prefer people
to be physically here which is more
helpful so I don't want to I don't want
to say we're going to do this and then
everybody no one shows up everybody's
online um but we know Senator delandro
we may want to so maybe we'll do it
Lottery everybody knows the lottery
building
is
yeah yeah it's just down the street it's
off yeah we get Manchester Street near
Bank Chevrolet it's not that far and
there's plenty of parking okay yeah so
one of we address a 14 Integra
drive if you go down keep on going down
Main Street what it right yep Main
Street there was Manchester Street um
you pass Bank Chevrolet on your left
take the next right that's Integra Drive
we're at the end right there's a sign
when you make the right this Lottery
yeah that's right across from where you
get on
106 no the other side of the valley it's
it's across of Airline Airport Road oh
okay okay
y all right any uh okay so the fourth at
Lottery uh any other business anybody
wants to bring up any other AG agenda
items that folks would like to see us
discuss next
week what what would the items we
talking next
we uh we haven't gotten there yet I I
have to figure it
out so um any any suggestions there it
would be helpful you could we reach out
to me
um I think we're I think we're all set
um so I will adjourn the meeting thank
you